so this right over here is the graph of
the function G of T it is a function of
T and let's define a new function let's
call it capital G of X and it's equal to
the definite integral between t is equal
to negative 3 and T is equal to X of our
lower case G of T G of T DT so given how
we have just given how we have just
defined capital G of X let's see if we
can evaluate some about let's see if we
can find some values so let's evaluate
the function capital G at X is equal to
4
let's also evaluate the function capital
G at X is equal to 8 and I encourage you
to pause the video right now and try to
think about these on your own and then
we can work through them together so
let's tackle capital G of 4 first so
this is going to be this is going to be
well if X is equal to 4 this this top
boundary is going to be 4 so this is
going to be the definite integral of G
of T between t is equal to negative 3
and T is equal to 4 G of T G of T DT now
what's that going to be equal to well
let's see let's look at this graph here
so we have negative 3 so this T is equal
to negative 3 which is right over here
T is equal to negative 3 and we're going
to go all the way to T is equal to 4 let
me circle that in orange all the way to
T is equal to 4 which is right over here
so this is one way to think about this
is this is going to be the area above
the T axis and below the graph of G so
it's going to be this area right over
here that is above the T axis and below
the graph of G of T but we're not going
to add to it this area because this area
over here I'll shaded in yellow this
area I'm shading in yellow over here
this is going to be negative why is it
going to be negative because we want the
area that is above T and below G this is
the other way or
round.this is below the t-axis and above
the graph of G so one way to think about
it is we could split it up so we could
and actually let me just clear this out
so we have more space so this right over
here is going to be equal to the
integral I'll do that in this purple
color the integral from T equals
negative 3 to 0 of G of T DT plus I'll
do this in the yellow color plus the
integral from 0 T equals 0 to T is equal
to 4 of G of T DT now what are each of
these going to be well this is just a
triangle where the base is 3 the base
has length 3 the height is length 3 so
it's going to be 3 times 3 which is 9
times 1/2 because 3 times 3 would give
us the area of this entire square but
this triangle is half of that so let's
go this right over here is going to be
4.5 this is going to be 4.5 and then
what's this area in yellow well let's
see we have a triangle its basis or its
width here is 4 its height is 4 4 times
4 is 16 which would be the area of this
entire square we take half of that it's
8 now we don't just add it to it because
once again this is going to be negative
area the graph over here is below below
the T axis so this we would say we would
this integral is going to evaluate to
negative 8 once again why is it negative
8 because the graph is below below the T
axis and so what do we get we get G of 4
this which is this area essentially
minus this area 4.5 minus 8 is going to
be let's see 4 minus 8 is negative 4 at
a point 5 that's negative 3 point 5
negative 3 point 5 now let's try to
figure out what G of 8 is so G of 8 and
if you couldn't figure it out the first
time around try to pause the video again
and now that we figured out G of 4 try
to figure out what G of 8 is
well G of a is one way to think about
it's going to be that - that area and
then we're going to add and then we're
going to figure out the area and then
we're going to have two more areas to
think about we're going to go all the
way to eight so actually let me make
draw the line there so we're going to
have to think about we're going to think
about this whole area now this whole
area now and then we're going to think
about this one so we could write this is
going to be equal to the integral
between let me do that purple color so
it's going to be this this integral
which is the integral between negative T
equals negative three and zero G of T DT
Plus this entire yellow region right now
the part that we looked at before plus
this part over here so I'll just write
that as plus the definite integral
between T is equal to zero and six G of
T DT and then finally plus the definite
integral between T is equal to six and T
is equal to eight G of T DT now we
already know that this first one
evaluates to four point five so that one
is four point five now what's this one
going to be we have a triangle whose
base is length six height is four six
times four is 24 times one half is going
to get us 12 so this is going to be that
over there is 12 and then finally what
is this area oh and we have to be
careful this is below the T axis and
above the graph so this is going to be a
negative 12 and then finally we have
this area which is once again going to
be a positive area it's below the graph
and above the T axis and so let's see 2
times 4 is 8 times 1/2 is 4 so we're
going to have plus 4 plus 4 and so what
do we have we end up with four point
five plus four is eight point five
- twelve so this is going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to eight point
eight minus twelve would be negative
four plus five it is negative three
point five again now why did these two
things end up being the same well think
about what happened here when we went
from capital G of four to capital G of
eight we subtracted we subtracted this
value right over here and we added this
value right over here and you see that
these two triangles have the same area
so we subtracted and added the same
amount to get the same exact value